Stéphane billon
bonsoir le scooter volé du fils Sarkozy
retrouvait grâce à des prélèvements ADN
Sarkozy faut pas l'emmerder on lui a
piqué sa femme l'an passé pareil elle a
été retrouvée ils avaient tout ses
mensurations son numéro de châssis
l'état de la carrosserie et un
certificat de non-gage et comme quoi
elle était plus avec Jacques Martin
le philosophe André Glucksmann rejoint
les personnalités soutenant Sarkozy faut
qu'il fasse une boulette maintenant
assez obligé émigrés en Suisse rouler
bourré dans un couloir de bus ou
déclarer qui veut couper la [ __ ] des
noirs
à Orange un élu UMP avait transformé sa
villa en bordel l'établissement a été
fermé je vois pas pourquoi c'est pile
poil les valeurs de l'UMP écrites dans
le Figaro cette semaine travail autorité
responsabilité masturbation fellation
à Paris les habitants de la rue
d'Enghien où se trouve le QG de Sarkozy
se plaignent les RG les aurait
interrogés et fichiers faut pas
s'énerver la rue d'Enghien est une rue
test si Nicolas était lu ce sont toutes
les rues de France qui seront
interrogées et fichiers on voit si ça
marche
le pire c'est être noir et habiter rue
d'Enghien contrôlé par Sarkozy castré
par Sevran
on passe en partie socialiste faut être
équitable dans la saloperie sinon le CSA
se fâche
Ségolène Royal a déjoué un canular
téléphonique de Gérald daron se faisant
passer pour François Hollande Gérald lui
a proposé une nuit coquine à la
permanence du PS ouais c'était trop gros
comme ficelle sur les proposer un débat
participatif ou une visite de Jarnac
sur les marchés et les socialistes
installent des boîtes à idées alors
soyez gentil mettez pas de conneries
dans les boîtes style la Corse
indépendante ou vive le Québec libre
parce que vous vous savez que c'est pour
rire mais Ségolène
dans match un reportage sur Ségolène
jeune fille au pair ah bah voilà tout
s'explique c'est là qu'elle a fait ses
armes en politique tais-toi virgule
manges ta soupe point partage avec ton
voisin point d'exclamation
à Rome lors d'un défilé de haute couture
un styliste à proposer une robe Ségolène
Royale une robe Dominique vonet est à
l'étude pour les femmes qui en ont marre
que leur mari leur saute dessus tous les
soirs il paraît que ça fait débander
tout de suite ça et du déodorant Ushuaïa
sous les bras vous êtes sûr de plus être
emmerder société
en Mayenne record de natalité 33
naissances pour 1663 habitants va
falloir équiper le secteur en
congélateur
ça c'est pour Gaccio
dans les lieux publics 165000
fonctionnaires font appliquer la loi à
des fonctionnaires on va déjà on pourra
fumer entre midi et deux l'après-midi à
partir de 16h les jours fériés et au
mois de mai avec tous les ponts qui a
cloper tant qu'on veut
[Applaudissements]
qui bossent ou je sais pas
cinéma
uneanimité autour de l'île au trésor
film avec Gérard Jugnot pour le Parisien
un naufrage pour le JDD un sabordage
pour VSD une piraterie infestée par
l'ennui si votre enfant a mal travaillé
à l'école emmenez-le ça ou un conte de
Marlène Jobert généralement il s'en
souviennent
déclaration de Jean-Pierre Mocky
Stéphane Bern physique de cinéma
il y a pas de vanne c'est ça la vanne
télévision une interview de Marc-Olivier
Fogiel ma dernière rencontre avec l'abbé
Pierre on espère que c'est pas ça qui
l'a tué
on termine par une nouvelle qui réjouira
Pascal Sevran bientôt une pilule pour
homme bloquera l'éjaculation c'est moi
douloureux qu'un coup de ma chaîne sur
la [ __ ] à la semaine prochaine merci
beaucoup
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu